are you married no no did you have a  girlfriend no I don't but if I did miss  lane you'd be the first to know about it  Margot Kidder the actress best known for  her role as Lois Lane in the 1978  Superman film has died at 69 years old  ét can confirm the actress passed away  peacefully in her sleep on Sunday at her  home in Livingston Montana Kidder  starred opposite Christopher Reeve in  Superman and three sequels she continued  to act in film and TV  most recently starring in the 2017 movie  the neighborhood she also had roles on  stage including the Vagina Monologues on  Broadway Kidder suffered from a very  public battle with bipolar disorder and  was briefly homeless in 1996 prompting  her to become an advocate for mental  health she was married three times  although she'd been single since the 80s  she is survived by her only child  daughter Maggie Mick Wayne  you